you know this next gentleman called in
and this this guy had a suggestion that
I thought was super interesting let's
take it right here guy you know what I
feel rich Raleigh North Carolina rich
out of Raleigh Raleigh rich huh rich got
that cash rich got them coins baby
bankroll Richie huh Richie with that
bread huh stacks on stacks on stacks
rickety rackets wrecks Richie right
there he is Richie rad Richie with them
right somewhat hey look at the former
82nd airborne paratrooper served in Iraq
twice at the end of ten years I'm done
with angry mobs and unfortunately that's
how you you calm down disobedience was
with hammer it all like well what I was
going to say was you know I'm not a
mayor and police chief I was it you had
female between east being down in
certain citizens prevent any kind of
investigation or anything you know
misbehavior that's when they happen we
had a female that conducted the search
here that handled that and maybe this
was you know it has to come down to is
there's a black you just need more black
cop black cop black cop deal with the
black people perpetrators whatever black
gladiator gang brother thank you for the
call that's it that's that's um you know
that's something to think about there I
was thinking about this as well man what
if you call a police station you say hey
you know I have you know I got two white
guys over here
I got a you know I got one Latino and I
got a you know one Neapolitan you know
and that's who so that's they send you
that style of officers then you have
just to find a way to take the race
element out of it you know to take it
and to make it not a you know to make it
not a racial thing it'd be interesting
you know you like a can you send
somebody over yeah I need a guy I got a
Dutch somebody over here that's Dutch
and I got a mmm to vietze over here you
know throwing rocks and they're like oh
[ __ ] we understaffed over here all we
got is you know we have a black guy and
we have a Croatian female I don't think
we can help you we can't help you
tonight you know that'd be crazy
wouldn't it but would that be
interesting if they had you know if they
had certain ethnicity alter you officers
you match it up you match this you match
that you know I'm just thinking outside
of the box here thinking of different
ways because if if things continue to be
a problem then then you have to try and
you know think of some different options
you know like I used to work at that
place what was that place called in
Charleston it was called a frozen
options and you could get a different
something a little you know frozen candy
or a frozen ice treat or something and
get you something get you a little
cousin a little you know grape something
low eskimo sour sauce or something
sipper good evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one
just watch this one watches one